the council today had an exchange of
views on the subject of the state of
advancement of simplification measures
of the ca p among the main measures for
simplification which were proposed by
the member states greening and rural
development at the forefront of our
minds the ministers were also informed
about issues linked to international
trade in agricultural products the
Commission told us that it intended to
continue to work with the Russian
authorities seeking for possible opening
for exports from Europe for pig meat
products which are only under sanitary
embargo when it comes to development of
agricultural markets and recent measures
for support the Commission told us that
the milk market is stabilizing although
the pig meat market seems to be getting
worse and worse we are going to have a
number of business related missions in
2016 and we've updated the meeting today
in relation to tea tip there was a round
of negotiations in recent times we were
still anxious to see more movement on
the part of the United States across a
number of areas today I took the
opportunity to announce further measures
in relation to simplification the first
one I think was of major significance to
farmers is the preliminary checking
system that we are going to introduce at
the time of at the time of application
date in it before the application is
formally lodged in the IT system the
member station are managing paying
agency will have an opportunity over 35
days to give an opportunity to the
farmer to correct some of the issues if
there is a mistake made on the
application form without penalty another
issue that I've taken on board is the
the need to reduce the number of under
spot checks and if the member states are
paying agency has significant investment
made in there I X system and we will
reduce over a period
time from five percent sample under spot
checks to one percent on market
developments I announced the new pic
meet aids the private storage scheme
which hopefully will be agreed on the
second to December and which will come
into effect on the early in the new year